nous parlons il ya un instant de la
crise sanitaire une crise sanitaire vous
le savez qui c'est mieux aussi en crise
économique parmi les aides de l'état a
lancé pour venir en aide aux secteurs
économiques le prêt garanti par l'état
il est destiné à l'ensemble des
entreprises
c'est un dispositif qui a permet
d'obtenir un prêt auprès d'une banque
qui sera donc garanti par l'état dans
les yvelines plus de onze mille sociétés
ont bénéficié de ce dispositif pour un
montant total de 2,2 milliards d'euros
alors on en parle avec deux invités
inquiétant plateau ses criques
ordinariat bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
dirigeant du restaurant la fontaine qui
est notamment dédiée aux spécialités de
la mer et il est basé à montigny le
bretonneux il compte sept salariés et
également en visioconférence avec nummi
qu'elle croit thorium qui qui est avec
nous bonsoir visioconférence bonsoir
dirigeants jouent de la société
automation 2007 une pme de 16 salariés
installée à coignières dans le domaine
de l'industrie également en plateau avec
nos de la rédaction de tv 78 nicolas
dans le piémont soir bonsoir grégory
pouvez-vous déjà nous rappeler quelles
sont les conditions de ce prêt garanti
par l'état là vous l'avez dit grégorien
toutes les entreprises peuvent
bénéficier d'un prêt garanti par l'état
le demande auprès de leur banque
le montant peut aller jusqu'à 25 % de
leur chiffre d'affaires l'entreprise ne
rembourse rien pendant un an
et c'est au bout de cette année que le
remboursement peut commencer par exemple
les premiers remboursements dpg octroyé
en 2001 vont commencer en mars prochain
et dernière chose grégory dp jeu sont
encore disponibles jusqu'au 30 juin 2021
mais quelles sont les entreprises qui
sont concernés justement pour ces jeux
et bien lloris se sont toutes les
entreprises qui ont été touchées par la
crise sanitaire ne pense notamment aux
entreprises fermées sur décision
administrative mais autre situation des
pg ont été octroyés aussi par précaution
pour certaines entreprises
écoutez les explications de christophe
sanguins dont il est le directeur de
l'agencé banque populaire val de france
à montigny le bretonneux
l'entreprise cible du psg n'ont pas
pleinement utiliser ce dispositif il en
moyenne utilisée 50% de leurs capacités
la chef d'entreprise ayant à l'esprit
qu'il se devait de rembourser son
soutien on privilégier d'autres leviers
ils ont vraiment eu une attitude
responsable de précaution et ça se voit
d'ailleurs sur le solde de leurs comptes
bancaires
en revanche on a les activités telles
que l'était la chair et l'événementiel
où ils ont donc on peut aussi utiliser
ce dispositif
il en est de même pour les entreprises
ont un lien avec le secteur automobile
ayant un fort impact économique dans les
départements et un ans après nicolas
quelles sont les différentes options et
pour les entreprises justement qui ont
bénéficié de ce pays les entreprises ont
le choix d'abord elles peuvent
directement rembourser le prêt c'est à
dire qu'une entreprise qui ont emprunté
100 mille euros rembourse directement
cent mille euros au bout d'un an
d'autres choix sont possibles pour les
entreprises elles peuvent décider de
rembourser sur cinq ans et la dernière
décision qui a été prise dernièrement
par bercy c'est le ministère de
l'économie un c'est la possibilité aux
entreprises de commencer le
remboursement de le décaler encore d'un
an
c'est notamment le cas pour les
entreprises qui sont encore en
difficulté et les banques commencent
notamment à recevoir les retours des
entreprises en ont un premier retour
on a déjà les premiers retours
actuellement en moyenne sur un
amortissement sur cinq ans on ne
dépassera pas les 2 75% sur les premiers
retours clients que nous avons 80 %
optent pour un amortissement sur cinq
ans dont 50 % avec le report
supplémentaire 15%
un amortissement entre les quatre ans et
16% sur l'avancement du prêt est juste
avant de vous redonner la parole de
nicolas donc je reprécise si vous nous
rejoignez que nous avons deux invités là
et en plateau ses criques ordinariat en
dirigeant du restaurant la fontaine à
montigny le bretonneux vous avez vous
bénéficié de ce pays à hauteur de 137
1000 euros est également donc en
visioconférence à michael croit torrio
qui est dirigeant de la société
automation 2000 qui est basée à croix à
coignières et vous donc c'est le contre
exemple puisque vous avez décidé de ne
pas avoir recours à ce psg à nicolas
vous avez des questions justement pour
nos invitations justement qu'il tord
dinan rien est ce que vous comptez
rembourser directement le prêt au mois
de mars ou au vu de la situation par
rapport à la restauration vous souhaitez
peut être différée d'un an encore le
début du remboursement
non je pense qu'on va être obligé de
demander en différé supplémentaire de
voilà les restaurants sont toujours pas
ouvert sur 2020 on a été fermé plus de
cinq mois qui a presque la moitié de
l'année
or plus on a été fermé sur les mois les
plus forts c'est à dire juin novembre et
décembre ce sont les mois les plus forts
de l'année pour la restauration
donc là il est évident qu'on ne peut pas
commencer à rembourser
même si on a la possibilité pour le
moment il serait pas prudent de se
séparer sa trésorerie est de commencer à
rembourser un prêt sur lequel on à la
facilité d'avoir un différé d'un an
supplémentaire
la réouverture en ciel qui a eu lieu
pendant quelques mois n'a pas eu assez
d'impact impact sur cette période
d'ailleurs on a été une bonne surprise
que quand on a ouvert au mois de juin
chez nous nous avons ouvert le vainqueur
22 juin ça a démarré très fort le public
est très demandeur donc ça a bien
démarré juin/juillet même où tu étais
très bien septembre aussi et puis fin
octobre il confinement qui est arrivé
est donc là aujourd'hui non je pense que
qu'il faut pour ce qui me concerne je
vais demander une année supplémentaire
c'est presque officiel à ce monde qui
regarde
c'est plutôt de la précaution en eut pas
seulement d'accord pas seulement alors
michael croître yeux vous vous êtes dans
le secteur industriel vous avez
enregistré une baisse de 20 % de votre
chiffre d'affaires et pourtant vous
n'avez pas demandé de prêts garantis par
l'état alors pourquoi ce choix
alors je dirais que c'est la première
chose par rapport à un prêt garanti par
les tailles pour garder sa trésorerie
j'estime que si la trésorerie permet
qu'on n'a pas de problème de trésorerie
on a une responsabilité sociétale ne pas
peser plus que nécessaire sur le budget
de l'état et kiki auquel contribuent
tous et donc j'ai fait le choix parce
que la trésorerie de l'entreprise le
permettait de ne pas faire de prêts
garantis par l'état dit d'ailleurs de
reporter mais embaumé mais paiement de
charges sociales
quand on voit la situation de krikor
dynario on voit que par précaution il
préfère repousser le début de ce
remboursement et vous n'y avait pas de
de principe de précaution disons pour
votre société
alors fait tous des prévisions de
trésorerie on suit ça au jour le jour
j'avais des confrères par ailleurs chef
d'entreprise qui osent poser aussi des
fois des questions disant combat par
sécurité
je vais aller prendre un prêt garanti
par l'état la par les majors dit je leur
ai répondu très simplement que moi j
étais tout simplement opposé si je n'en
ai pas besoin
je ne vois pas pourquoi je prendrais un
prêt garanti par l'état sous prétexte ou
peut-être par sécurité si dans le futur
j'ai un problème
ça me permettra de simplifier la vie je
pars du principe qu'on fait un emprunt
qu'on en a besoin
fait appel à un pg aux comptes par la
pétanque et le cas de monsieur qui
dirigeait le restaurant la fontaine et
qui était pas notre cas et qui
heureusement je dirais on est chanceux
de ce côté là il n'y est pas encore
autre cas n'a toujours pas inscrit
si on reprend l'exemple de la fontaine
on l'a compris à un secteur de la
restauration qui a été fortement touchée
par cette crise épidémique est devenue
une crise économique
on imagine donc la nécessité vous l'avez
rappelé tout à l'heure d'avoir recours à
ceux des jeux concrètement ça vous a
servi à quoi se payer alors le pg a
servi
surtout à faire face aux frais fixes
monteil deux mesures qui ont été prises
tout site par le gouvernement les deux
étaient excellentes mon avis la toute
première ça a été le chômage partiel
évidemment donc les salariés ont été
mises à l'abri tout de suite ça a été
fait immédiatement
la deuxième c'était le pg e lp jeu
permet nous a permis de faire face aux
frais fixes de l'établissement qui se
situe entre 12 et 15 mille euros par
mois quand même donc on aurait pu
peut-être faire face un petit peu
quelques mois avec ça sans savoir ce qui
allait se passer dans les trois ou
quatre ou cinq mois ce2 qui arrivait
donc personne aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on nous sommes en 2021
il ya huit ou neuf fois de sa personne
n'imagine est aujourd'hui dans une
situation comme ça donc mon collègue
chef d'entreprise qui n'a pas eu besoin
du ps je sais bien c'est parfait ce tant
mieux j'espère pour lui que sa
trésorerie va pas en souffrir qui aura
pas des événements nouveaux qui vont
nous empêcher de travailler et que sa
situation ne va pas se dégrader parce
que c'est des choses qui peuvent aller
vite qu'ils le sont tout aussi bien
comment il semble que jeu et on va vous
faire réagir dans un instant unique elle
croître yeux ça vous a permis quand même
d'avoir une vision sur l'avenir tout de
même une petite vision sur l'avenir son
sens pge c'était plus difficile bien sûr
évidemment ce n'est pas vraiment une
vision sur l'avenir c'est à dire qu'il
ya une continuité dans l'établissement
tout simplement michael croit theuriau
vous souhaitiez réagir ce que l'on vient
d'entendre mais on imagine comprenait
aussi la situation par exemple des
restaurateurs qui ont dû avoir recours à
ces jeux complètement c'est à dire que
nous on a pu continuer de travailler ce
qui est pas été le cas de la
restauration et malheureusement c'est
pour ça je comprends tout à fait la
situation difficile dans laquelle il
comprend la nécessité de pge pour eux
nous on a eu la chance de pouvoir
continuer de travailler
on a continué à enregistrer des
commandes et à fabriquer et à les
expédier c'est en cela que nous on n'a
pas eu de problème de trésorerie parce
qu'on a continué à à vendre et donc
aussi à acheter nos fournisseurs et
tant que les projections trésorerie
qu'on fait au fur et à mesure les
voyants ne sont pas à l'orangé ou au
rouge
et bien c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas fait
de p g même si on l'a enregistré une
baisse significative de notre chiffre
d'affaires
une connerie pour une dernière question
mickaël poté rue quand on voit que bercy
a décidé de prolonger
du coup la possibilité de demander un pg
au 30 juin 2021 en fonction de
l'évolution de la conjoncture économique
par rapport à votre activité est ce que
vous pourriez 1 envisagé de prendre un
pg e d'ici au 30 juin
je ne l'exclurais pas mais je regarderai
vraiment très près parce que le but du
jeu c'est pas demain si j'ai juste si si
j'ai 99 % de chances ne peut pas en
avoir besoin c'est pas pour les 1%
restant que j'irai naturellement
merci d'avoir été avec nous par
visioconférence michael croit torrio je
rappelle que vous êtes le dirigeant de
la société automation en 2000 pme de 16
salariés qui est basée à coignières et
merci à krikor dinars yankee a été avec
moi au plateau dirigeants du restaurant
la fontaine qui est à montigny le
bretonneux et on le rappelle spécialisée
dans les dans les produits de la mer
voilà merci d'avoir été avec nous vous
comptez vous cette salariée un jeu n'est
pas précisée à montigny-le-bretonneux et
merci également à nicolas landry de la
rédaction de tv 78